Alright, let's work through the solution. First we import
the json and request libraries. Then we provide the URL
that we're going to be making our API call to.
Then we make our API call using the request library,
and load the results into a dictionary. Finally, we
print out the name of the number one top artist.
In the data dictionary, we will look at the top
artist's key. Then we look at the artist key there.
We look at the first entry. And we look
at the name parameter. As you can see, the URL
is the biggest difference between this code and the sample
code in the previous video. Mainly I've just changed the
parameters and the URL variable. To make sure that I'm
getting the top artists, I am calling the geo.gettopartists method.
I'm also passing the country parameters in by setting the
parameter country equal to Spain. And once I have retrieved
the data, I'm loading it into a
json file in this line. Data equals json.loads(data).
This let's me find the top performing
artist quickly and easily by accessing it almost
like a python dictionary. You could also load the data as json and try to
just parse it with the regex, but
I personally think that would be really painful.